foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the book club I'm
Michael Knowles and for this episode we
are going to do something we've never
done on the book club before we are
going to pry open a science textbook but
it's it's much less dry than it sounds
this is a very old school science
textbook that's not even really a
textbook it's a dialogue concerning the
Two Chief World Systems by Galileo but
first in our fast-paced world it is
tough to make reading a priority
especially in the books it is long it's
very difficult at least it used to be at
thinker.org they summarize the key ideas
from new and noteworthy non-fiction
giving you access to an entire library
of great books in bite-sized form you
can read or listen to hundreds of titles
in a matter of minutes from old classics
like Dale Carnegie's had a Win Friends
and Influence People to recent
bestsellers like Jordan Peterson's 12
rules for life if you want to challenge
your preconceptions
if you want to expand your horizons if
you want to sound very very smart at
cocktail parties go to thinker.org that
is t-h-i-n-k-r dot org No E no time for
that start a free trial and put your
mind in motion we are going to put our
minds in motion talking about the motion
of the solar system the motion of the
universe and we will do that with an
actual scientist my guest Brian Keating
the chancellor distinguished professor
of physics at UC San Diego and the
author of losing the Nobel Prize Brian
thank you for being here it's a great
pleasure to be here Michael Brett I also
have to thank you you brought me
presents I did you're the first guest to
bring me presents including
a piece of the Moon yes you brought me
somehow a p i don't even know did you
did you hitch a ride with Richard
Branson or so I don't know if it was
delivered the old-fashioned way by the
United States Postal Service that's so
great you can get your very own uh
samples of the Moon if you were an
astronaut that would be one way to get
it expensive way to get it or you can
actually get them online there are
actually sources of getting slices of
the Moon and this is actually a proposed
of this book because the moon figures
greatly in the dialogue concerning the
Two Chief World Systems and it sort of
uh provides a foil to some of the
arguments against that of the
protagonist really portraying Galileo
himself this character salviati but I
thought it'd be good to just maybe
summarize what this book is and and how
it had an effect on me as a young
scientist and even greater effect is a
more mature scientist yes I think that's
a good idea because I think there might
be one or two people out there who
didn't get to finish the whole book
maybe it tops three that's right so yeah
could you just very briefly describe how
the book is uh designed and who the
characters are and why Galileo got
thrown into prison well we'll get into
that too
so it's it's an extremely important book
in the history of science for many
different reasons uh one of which is
that it's really laying out the
scientific method for the first time to
a popular audience this book was written
not in Latin which was the conversant
language for scientists of the day the
only language that Galilei was permitted
to write in he wasn't allowed to teach
in Italian because that would be
communicating to the Mass public and the
Catholic Church wasn't ready for that in
the early 1600s he was prohibited via a
Vatican injunction to do so so but in
this book he writes for a popular
audience and it's really perhaps the
first and might be the best example of
popular science writing it has no
equations of note so it's not a textbook
like we would encounter when you come
back and get your PhD someday yeah
perhaps in San Diego it has no equations
no formula nothing complicated presents
some data but but the beautiful thing
about this book is that it's literature
it's a work of literature uh
masquerading as a book about the way the
world or really the universe could be
arranged and that is really the
distinction that's set into motion the
Scientific Revolution which we now kind
of take for granted in our technological
age but if you ever stop and think about
it how do you really know that the earth
goes around the Sun it doesn't appear
that way right things would be different
according to our natural Notions of how
motion and and mass and other things
work so Galileo is responding to that
the perception that we feel like the
Earth is stationary and it appears as if
the sun and the stars are orbiting
around us some more than others here in
Hollywood right there that's right all
orbiting around each and every one of us
well you make this point on the textbook
most science textbooks I've read do not
have characters they do not have a
storyline they do not take so that the
book is divided into four days of these
conversations and there are three
principal characters that's right so the
first character is a sort of an
interlocutor this is who's job is really
to kind of translate between the two
other protagonists in the story one by
the name of salviati and he really has
the words of Galileo these were all
three real uh existing human beings that
existed that Galileo knew two of whom
salviati and segreto had passed away
decades earlier when Galileo wrote this
in 1632 when it was published but there
were true people the third person by the
name of simplicio aka the simpleton he's
you know considered by Galileo Galileo
describes them sort of like an amalgam
of maybe a sixth Century you know a
scientist and a commentator on Aristotle
right so far down you say you've got Sal
salviati he's the one and there are two
other characters we should mention
Copernicus yes who's saying that the
Earth revolves around the Sun correct
and Ptolemy the older view who says that
the sun revolves around the earth and so
those are the two views that are being
debated and you've got salviati who
Galileo agrees with savior the Savior
right and he's representing the
copernican view this the view that we
now hold right that the earth goes
around the Sun that's right you've got
the interlocutor as you say segreto
who's kind of mediating between these
guys
they both use their real names
so how come the guy who's representing
Ptolemy and really Aristotle too they
don't call him Ptolemy they don't call
them Aristotle they don't use his real
name they use this name of this obscure
commentator simpletio uh why did why do
they call them simple too well I think
Galileo is was known as a brilliant
scientist but he had he had immense
flaws he had immense uh challenges to
his character that ultimately what led
to his undoing one of which is that he
would do things that were precisely the
impolitic thing to do such as take the
index's prohibition of copernican work
and the logic that goes behind the
Aristotelian earth-centered view of the
cosmos and he would put those in the
very injunction against him he put those
in the words of the simpleton namely the
pope who would later become Pope Pope
Urban yeah who would preside over the
the holy office or the Holy See you know
I would say it's like a euphemism like
the IRS is the money donation service
you know you just you just donate your
money to the holy office yes that's
exactly what it was it was the
Inquisition and yeah and and it true in
truth Galileo had a lot to it was it was
very much at fault when it came to the
ultimate you know culmination of that
story but but maybe before we get there
we talk about why this is such a unique
work of literature as you say there are
no equations not textbook or it's not
like any textbook we would see nowadays
it's what we would call you know popular
science or a trade book meaning that
it's meant for the general audience so
that's why I think readers today in
addition to the scientifically brilliant
ideas and logic and philosophy theology
the most weighty subjects the the
ultimate issues that Mankind we just
don't have as much time to think about
anymore and maybe they had more time
back then you know there's a fewer
options on on YouTube
et cetera Netflix
uh but uh but nevertheless this is so
brilliantly captivating that immediately
sold out all across the continent
Galileo was world famous even even in a
very early age it's almost 400 year old
book we have coincidentally we have a
first edition here from 1632 correct
they they all sold out so honestly it
was obviously a friend of ours was able
to get there in 1632 grab this copy of
the book and it's funny because when the
book eventually is put on the list of
forbidden books it was too late because
the things sold out within three days or
something yeah so so I I got that from a
friend who got it on Amazon you know 400
year delivery that's always a
little-known aspect of Amazon that you
could get
um so this is from a friend who's a
collector of these rare books and has
first edition copies of it and it's uh
generously loaned it to us for today and
and this book is so brilliantly
displayed it has wonderful illustrations
including the cover the front this piece
as it's known which depicts these these
wonderful characters which uh were later
used in another book after Galileo was
supposedly tortured and imprisoned which
didn't really happen you wrote another
book also called the dialogue and
dialogue format about two different
types of science he called it and that
really revolved around what we call
mechanics and Material Science today but
the same three characters come back in
this work that was published only a few
years before he passed away in 16 142 or
so what makes this book so spectacularly
important and revelatory for me is that
you can be a great scientist and also a
great writer and Galileo was This
brilliant amalgam of all these different
traits including the human foibles flaws
and peccadillos that we all have and
there's a stereotype that scientists are
just these Geniuses walking wikipedias
expert knowledge trust the scientists I
trust you I don't trust others you
shouldn't trust me so scientists are the
least trusting of other scientists I
never mean to say oh what did you
discover oh yeah the great go to publish
it yeah here's your Stockholm novel
sounds good to me yeah scientists have
the most doubt and that's because as you
know the word science means knowledge
well the only way that you get knowledge
is by subjecting it to experimental
empirical evidence well what about
something like as I've talked about
previously the Multiverse for which
there is no evidence existing currently
it doesn't mean there never will be
right but to what level should you trust
a scientist that's purely speculating on
theoretical findings it could be purely
theoretical it doesn't mean it's wrong
yeah the theory of evolution we have
evidence for the theory of evolution
right what Galileo does so brilliantly
here is he presents these two Theses
obviously he's partial to the copernican
the heliocentric uh model of the of the
universe but again I ask as the only
homework assignment that you'll get on
Prager University uh this quarter uh
maybe you'll get more in future quarters
is to think about it what if you were
teleported back to 1631 before this book
came out and you're trying to
communicate all these wonderful
discoveries of the past 4 nearly 400
years how would you prove the most
simple postulates of all that the Earth
is a sphere that the Earth rotates on
its axis once per 24 hours and that once
per 365 and a quarter days it orbits
around the Sun in motion it sure as heck
doesn't feel like that and that's the
subject of day one in the first day of
this book uh in the second day they get
into a little bit more obscure
observations rather than just purely
philosophical arguments on the nature of
how things fall down and there are
things you are attracted to the centers
occupy them for the most part in day one
and day three they start talking about
the composition of the Earth is sort of
like a magnet and it's maybe it's made
of little tiny magnets all kind of
congealed together maybe it's not what
is the nature of the surface of the Moon
if it's perfect it was thought to be
perfectly smooth it doesn't look smooth
right it looks it has some imperfections
in it doesn't it and so uh so Galileo
had discovered he didn't invent the
telescope but he was the first
observational astronomer to look through
a telescope conceive a scientific
hypothesis subjected to tests and refine
his model and that's why you shouldn't
trust the scientists because at any one
of those stages he had great blunders I
mean he was really brilliant I always
say you know he could have had a great
career if he didn't make these blunders
Einstein had great blunders there's not
a serious scientist who hasn't made a
serious mistake and with Galileo
fortunately or unfortunately those
mistakes usually evolved around the
politics of the day yes not the science
this reminds me this trusting scientist
because it occurs to me when I think of
all these I think well Ptolemy is a
scientist right and some Tycho Bry is a
scientist and all these other other guys
and so they get things wrong right
there's a great line in the second day
and it this is uh segreto the
interlocutor is the one and he's
recounting a story which has by the way
now become a cliche and uh he's he's uh
talking to this guy who's a follower of
Aristotle and Ptolemy right and uh
he asked this man whether he was at last
satisfied and convinced that the nerves
originated in the brain and not in the
heart previously they had thought that
the nerves come from the heart but now
because of scientific inquiry we know we
know it's in the brain so he asks this
devotee of Aristotle do you are you now
satisfied and the philosopher after
considering a while answered you have
made me see this matter so plainly and
palpably that if Aristotle's texts were
not contrary to it stating clearly that
the nerves originate in the heart I
should be forced to admit it to be true
but Aristotle said it so I don't care
what I've seen right I believe him over
my lion eyes all right so I look at that
and I say almost everything that uh
Aristotle said was brilliantly wrong in
other words he would say things like a
heavier object falls faster than a
lighter object yeah and and Galilee
would say what if you have this heavy
object like a book but in midair somehow
they didn't say with a laser beam but
they say let's say it breaks apart
mid-air now does it fall slower or let's
say just a tiny bit of it breaks off so
now the tiny bit is lighter than that of
course not it's absurd they could have
figured that out you know other than 300
BC when right when Aristotle was was
promulgated now he had some interesting
ideas uh but it turns out that almost
all of them were wrong and so what
Galileo the physical Center I'm at a
physical side
in terms of politics very interesting
um but uh but when you look at what
Galileo I always say if you have the
choice between a weather woman who's
half right and half wrong or one that's
always wrong always choose the one
that's always wrong because you'll just
do the opposite that Galileo used to
great effect huh the ultimate conclusion
of this book in day four turns out to be
wrong and it actually is only thanks to
the pope who enjoined him to not publish
uh the book with his original title
which was the spectacular which would do
so well in a b testing the original
title that Galileo wanted was on the
flux and reflux of the Earth's Tides wow
where do I run away Amazon it's blank
book but no no but it wouldn't be a
blank book but actually it's a chat as
the subject of the fourth chapter about
the fourth day which Galileo felt was a
dispositive conclusion that was
inescapable that because the Earth has
oceans on it and because it spins on its
axis as he had proved in the preceding
days as it rotates around the Sun just
as this vodka no just as water sloshes
about in this bottle as I rotate and
revolve it so too are tides on the
Earth's surface caused by such a
phenomenon right in fact we now know
that it is indeed the Moon that causes
the Earth's tide the moon has a
gravitational force field that acts on
the earth and tugs on the oceans a
little bit more and a little bit less on
different sides of it four times a day
yeah now Galileo had the data conclusion
was absolutely wrong because it was he
fell victim to what we call confirmation
bias scientists are very subject to it
I've personally been subject to it when
you want to prove something so badly
maybe it's to get tenure maybe it's to
get a prizer to get attention or maybe
because your theory is so beautiful it
can't be wrong as Einstein used to say
yeah uh that you've sort of fall in love
with it and you discard contrary
evidence Gala Leo fell victim to it and
ultimately the pope did him a real favor
by forcing him to change it to this much
more interesting and provocative time
this is very funny that because people
totally it's not that they even
misunderstand the Galileo incident it's
not that they're ignorant of it it's
that they know so much that isn't so
they know things that just didn't happen
so you know in the traditional way the
story is told Galileo This brilliant guy
is totally oppressed by the Inquisition
and by the Catholic church and these
awful ladies tortured he's thrown in a
prison cell it's you know it's the worst
anti-intellectual anti-scholarship thing
that's ever happened and that isn't
quite true first of all the pope
actually helps him because he gets that
that theory wrong but the pope had been
sort of Pals with Galileo right proverb
in the eighth and then how does Galileo
repay him he names his character
simpleton in the book and and there's
another great line from the era from
another pal of Galileo's Cardinal
baronius who they were very uh I won't
say they were tolerant of these sort of
scientific inquiries but they weren't
you know burning these the Galileo at
the stake or anything like that and
baronius famously said
that the Bible teaches us how to go to
heaven not how the heavens go it does
not it does not form these Rock Solid
canonical scientific conclusions about
the world and so you can be open to
inquiry you say that Galileo runs a foul
of the Inquisition
because he was impolitic yeah
I think I think he had an agenda and I
think his uh scientific agenda sort of
superseded some of the reason in his
interpersonal skills so there's a joke
how do you know a scientist is outgoing
he looks at your shoes when he talks to
you instead of his own so Galileo had
great flaws he was uh sort of boorish in
his personal life he wasn't the greatest
father he had two daughters and a son
out of wedlock but he was a religious
man he did believe and he considered
himself a good Catholic which is why the
ultimate you know the ultimate verdict
as you might say yeah was that he was
guilty of Suspicion of heresy not heresy
itself or which he would have been
tortured uh it was sort of done under
threat of torture and you can argue if
that's the same he certainly was never
tortured in the classic sense the he did
have to bow down and kiss the Pope's
Rings Etc
um but given the house we all did in
those days right right yes my students
are not in there but uh but but the
point of Galileo being they're actually
books called you know Galileo goes to
jail and other are myths you know so
there's this narrative that was
established after this book because of
that incident the Galileo Affair uh as
it's known that really chose to pit this
as the first battle between science and
God and that Galileo you know they they
imprisoned reason uh Entre there's
another book called on trial for reason
suggesting that you know merely because
of his ideas now I ask you
um there are comparisons made you know
Etc but what if I came up with some idea
that we're about to collide with an
enormous black hole and you're the pr
your president Knowles and uh you're the
most powerful ruler on Earth
um it's it's a question if something
could undermine and cause pure panic and
uh and and debate and and just cause
maybe perhaps there's nothing good that
could come of it and you know that yeah
do you have an obligation to reveal that
if indeed you thought it's compatible
with somewhat of the Catholic Church's
worldview to to go against what Galileo
was saying right so I think there are a
lot of myths about scientists and
there's certainly a lot of myths about
Galileo and how he was treated
ultimately okay but at the very least
yeah you've you've convinced me you you
you've affirmed for me what I what I had
uh always known automation bias because
it's confirmation bias because I I
always like uh digging in at Galileo so
they didn't throw them in jail for being
a scientist they threw him in jail for
being a jerk but you say okay he doesn't
get tortured that's a total myth but he
does go to jail surely so he was uh he
was sentenced to house imprisonment and
I was uh lucky enough to host a
conference in his very prison namely his
final villa villa de gallo Leo outside
of Florence and it's a small town called
archetri Which is less than a couple
kilometers for the from the convent
where his daughters were serving as nuns
so they served as nuns uh within within
walking distance of their father and
they would communicate with him uh he
did continue to write books and and see
visitors and he was by no means I always
say you know Bernie Madoff would trade
jail cells in a second yeah it's
Sumptuous uh not to say that you know he
might not have wanted to travel
elsewhere he was also very old he was in
firm he had kidney problems probably uh
and ultimately he lived about another
nine years or so after the after the
sentence was handed down but it was by
no means a torturous existence he
actually as I say wrote books conducted
final observations and some of them went
into what they consider his most
important book a second dialogue between
these three wonderful characters called
the discoursee the discussion on Two
Chief Sciences you've assigned me now
more homework that I have to I have to
it's it's so interesting to me that when
we talk about science it has become such
a politicized term is now capital S the
Trademark Sign over the E and you hear
these terms like science deny or we're
the party of science where the we own
science and
so often those stories are just complete
Legends Fabrications going back probably
most notably to Galileo where I would
suspect that the the people who uh who
are always inveying against the science
deniers they don't know the real story
of what happened to Galileo yeah it
provides a very convenient and and this
book Galileo uh goes to jail and other
myths about science goes through this
this you know very complicated interplay
between the church and Science and uh
puts to lie some of the myths about
these great characters giordana Bruno
who is another uh character very held
very closely to people for being burned
at the stake for postulating that stars
were actually other solar systems were
planets where people could live for
example
um but I think you know one thing to
give to to give a little bit of
upgrading to the Catholic church so
Galileo was never pardoned and actually
for me that caused me I was an altar boy
in the Catholic church at age 12 and I
did uh want to eventually go all the way
uh which would be becoming a pre East
and at that time I got my first small
telescope not unlike one that's back
there and the one homework assignment I
would love to give people here even in
the middle of La you can see the exact
same craters on the surface of the Moon
that Galileo saw you can see the
Glorious rings of Saturn you can see the
moons of Jupiter and other Heavenly uh
objects that inspired Galileo towards a
love towards an affirmation that there
was a higher power which is actually the
ultimate conclusion of the book If I may
please read one or one or two passages
that really speak so loudly and speak to
his poetic use of language he was not
just the dry science Professor like
Isaac Newton was or unreadable as
Copernicus might be this is the book
that really set into motion the future
Hawkings and Etc of the world the future
Keating so he says I do not presume to
be able to induce all the proper and
sufficient causes of those effects which
are new to me and which consequently I
have had no chance to think about what
I'm about to say I propose merely as a
key to open portals to a road never
before trodden by any anyone in a firm
hope that Minds more acute than mine
will broaden this road and penetrate
further along it than I have done in my
first revealing of it he's giving an
assignment he's enjoying people to take
up the the path that he has started on
but continue it meaning he's not the
last word and in fact the last word goes
to the Pope the last word in the book
Goes To None other than simplicio the
simpleton not too often you give the
simpleton the last word but you'll
indulge me in doing just the same
so uh before they break for drinks uh he
uh there's a long discourse by by
segreto and and simplicio said you need
not making excuses they are Superfluous
and especially to me being accustomed to
public debates I've heard disputants
countless times not merely Google angry
and excited at each other but even break
out into insulting speech and sometimes
come very close to blows but he
basically say I know if I had asked a
God in his infinite power and wisdom
could have conferred upon the watery
element the tides it's Observer super
Kingdom motion by other means of its
containing vessels both of which would
reply that he Capital H could have and
that he Capital H would have known how
to do this in many ways which are
undeniable to our minds he's giving the
last word to the church right and to
probe and and I think it was consonant
with his Viewpoint I don't think he
really he was an atheist by no means
there's no evidence for that you know
there's another there's another great
line God comes up a lot yeah we're here
than in most science mostly yeah and
it's not it's not merely I think as a
sort of gloss for his true atheistic
view insurance policy yeah you know
you've got to give him more credit than
that he's a much deeper thinker than
that and and he writes this is on day
three
he says I say that it is Brash for our
feebleness to attempt to judge the
reason for God's actions and to call
everything in the universe Vain and
Superfluous which does not serve us
because that's that's really a central
issue here right man is not sitting at
the very center of the universe if
Galileo is right right and so and and
why on Earth would would these heavenly
bodies not be perfectly smooth why would
they not why would they have these
imperfections it has no purpose it has
no service to Mankind and so he says
well I think it's a look it's a little
rash this is this is in the mouth of
salviati the the guy who's representing
Galileo it says I think it would be
Brash to just say oh yeah sorry
everything that doesn't serve us is vain
and pointless and God had no reason to
do that and then segreta the
interlocutor complicates this a little
he says say rather and I think you will
be speaking more accurately which we do
not know to serve us I believe that one
of the greatest pieces of arrogance or
rather Madness that can be thought of is
to say since I do do not know how
Jupiter or Saturn is of service to me
they are Superfluous and even do not
exist yes that's brilliant now that is a
beautiful complication here and and in a
way exposes the arrogance of even the
people that Galileo probably would side
with and who now think they side with
Galileo and you see Echoes of this in
the modern you know militant atheist
movements the Lawrence krauses Etc that
suggests well look at the Hubble Deep
Field and which is an image made by the
Hubble Space Telescope staring for weeks
at a time in a tiny Blank Spot in the
cosmo Cosmic wallpaper and discovering
that every every place you look there's
a Galaxy and they'll say well that
proves there's no God because there's
all this wasted space there's all these
wasted galaxies of which you know we
know nothing about we can never contact
Etc but just the same way who would look
at Jupiter and say oh well those moons
are Jupiter or the telescope itself oh
it's only good for looking up the moons
of Jupiter yeah that would be so
limiting the power of the telescope all
the more so to limit the power of God
and I'm not here to Advocate on behalf
or not I don't think it's as simple as
saying well Galileo believed in God or
Einstein might have believed even God so
I'm going to believe in God we know
Newton certainly believed in God
certainly did it but it was interesting
that people use this this as a cudgel to
really go after the biblical authorities
and to give them you know some
ammunition it's true that they've never
formally issued a pardon right to
Galileo which affected me greatly as a
kid but now I'm an adult and now you
have to look with a little bit more
wisdom which is not what the word
science means science knowledge well
even even this issue even the question
of of the Vatican apologizing to Galileo
only really even became a big one in the
mid to late 20th century right and then
I said okay maybe maybe we were a little
harsh on the guy and did you know that
the Vatican operates a series of
telescopes around the world why would
they do that I mean a lot of it is you
know as the psalmist says the heavens
declare the handiwork of God right and
wisdom begins with the fear of God now
again I'm not advocating on behalf of
any religion or even the existence of
God I'm just saying it's a question that
Galileo wrestled with yeah and it
behooves us to wrestle alongside of him
right and and not to make a caricature
out of him not to read the read him as
just a silly cartoon that is that
actually has nothing to do with his life
the way he's normally presented you
actually have to dig into the book but
it occurs to me uh you have put me at a
disadvantage here because simplesio has
to end this discussion even uh Brian
break for drinks on the canal that's
right now much like these characters we
will break for drinks on the canal Brian
thank you so much for being here another
book you ought to read is losing the
Nobel Prize you're gonna do that right
after you finish
the dialogue concerning the Two Chief
World Systems in the meantime we'll see
you next time I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the book club at prageru
thank you so much for watching this
episode of the book club on prageru
prageru is a 501c3 non-profit
organization so we rely on donations
from viewers like you to keep this
content on the air please consider
making a tax deductible contribution
today to help keep this content coming
thank you very much